c'est vrai que j'avais déjà présenté un
peu trop mais bon on va faire avec
ok d'autres suivent pas et b comme cela
l'a été mentionné donc je vais sortir un
peu du cadre qu'on a eu à entendre
depuis lors sur l'innovation et tous
nous allons aller c'est quelque chose de
différent qui est accroître la qualité
de ses connexions je crois que le plus
important pour ma part oppose ce que je
pense c'est que au delà d'être
performant au delà de ces compétences tu
as besoin d'avoir en réseau compétents
qui te permettra d'avancer qui te
permettra plus aisément d'atteindre des
objectifs donc parler d'un réseau nous
parlerons de bien l'élément mais je
préfère qu'on puisse passer de diapos et
ensuite on pourrait revenir là dessus
nous allons commencer par définir ce que
nous entendons par connexion
selon vous qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
connexion le dictionnaire larousse
définit une connexion comme étant un
lien un lien entre 2 ou voie à plusieurs
personnes donc je pourrais en relation
avec sakina par exemple on serait elle
deviendrait par exemple ma connexion ou
en d'autres thèmes
je pourrais être en relation avec plus
de monde et nous serons toujours vous
deviendrez automatiquement mais
connexion comme connexion vous pourriez
avoir un ami je crois que pour la
plupart d'entre vous nous avons plus
d'étudiants de notre assemblée donc vous
pourrez avoir comme connexion vos amis
de classe il est vraiment important que
vous puissiez maintenir les relations
que vous avez maintenant parce que j'ai
retenu une chose c'est que le monde est
dirigé par génération et aujourd'hui si
tu veux réussir aujourd'hui si tu veux
atteindre les soldes ce moment il
faudrait que tu puisses être entouré de
personnes compétentes des personnes que
avec lesquels tu as été en relation bien
avant et donc ta connexion pourrait être
l'ami que tu as donc un ami cela dit on
a mis deux classes quelqu'un que tu
rencontres et poux il est important de
pouvoir maintenir cette relation là au
delà d'un ami une connexion pourrait
être pauvre
modèle tu pourrais être en relation avec
en modèle que tu as
par exemple le mien ces étudiants thiam
parce que c'est un grand financier sept
ans c'est quelqu'un qui a fait ses
preuves qui a pleinement démontré son
potentiel est aujourd'hui qui est prisé
sur toutes les plateformes
donc c'est en grand modèle à qui tu
pourrais essayer d'être en relation en
relation comment tu me diras par exemple
que tidiane thiam c'est quelqu'un de
trop top et kitsch pourrait pas échangé
mais par exemple qui pourrait chercher à
avoir son 1000 tu pourrait chercher à
entrer en relation être des personnes
qui le connaissent indirectement et de
cette manière là ils pourront te conduit
par exemple à cette personne tu pourrais
échanger par mail et tout développer ton
réseau développé très tôt avec ta
connexion pourrait être également une
rencontre déjà content il pas quand on
parlait ils ont ainsi moins un produit
comme ayant participé à des conférences
de leadership et où je me rappelle quand
j'étais en inde à l'une de ses
conférences
j'étais juste assise à côté dans un
directeur d'entreprise et tout est là je
venais à peine de finir mon bac + 4 on
va dire le post grad j'ai donc c'était
juste après mon post gratuite
j'assistais à cette conférence et tout
et on était là en l'échangé et à la fin
que le monsieur m'a demandé mais qu'est
ce que vous avez fait et tout donc j'ai
changé avec lui j'ai bon je viens à
peine de finir mon master en tout et
dont votre nation par exemple et aucune
opportunité donc je m'apprête à 1 re
partie en afrique où aller dans un autre
pays la première réaction a été mais qui
te disent ah c'est pas faisable c'est
pas possible
moi je suis directeur d'une entreprise
qu'est ce que tu as fait de noix de plus
amples détails je te touche de je
t'offre un emploi et c'est comme ça que
pour la première fois j'ai eu un stage à
l'étranger donc vous dire que les
personnes qui sont à côté de vous sont
importantes il faut pouvoir les
valoriser il faut pouvoir échanger avec
eux je veux que tu puisse regarder ton
voisin john stahl et big up comique aux
aguets biden expo next few x yacht show
est on pouvait le dire à votre voisin
jordan jusqu'au val dieu je serai à
personne la plus importante pour toi
l'année qui vient donc promo numéro s'il
te plaît il vaut mieux que tu prennes
mon numéro parce que tu auras besoin
moi très bientôt voilà donc c'est un peu
ça c'est vraiment important surtout pour
les jeunes que vous êtes de pouvoir
développer votre réseau
le réseau est quelque chose qui vous
aiderait à faire la différence
je le répète le monde est dirigé par
génération aujourd'hui je prends un cas
simples
j'ai un ami par exemple à qui j'ai
étudié qui est tout aussi compétent et
je donne notre côté une autre personne
que je connais pas mais qui est
également compétent de vous à moi
le penchant qui est ce que j'embaucherai
dans mon entreprise peut vous à moi lamy
qui est tout aussi compétent mais au
delà de sa compétence je le connais donc
ça pourrait pencher plus en sa faveur
outre c'est vraiment important de
maintenir la relation que vous avez
maintenant j'en manceau 10e
ben je n'ai pas de quoi le plus
important c'est d'avoir mes diplômes
mais au delà des diplômes aux réseaux
d'eau permettra d'avancer et donc je
voudrais parler un peu des éléments des
éléments qui peuvent nous aider à
accroître notre réseau où nos connexions
l'un des éléments les plus importants
pour pouvoir développer son relationnel
ou pour pouvoir accroître son réseau
d'amis c'est d'avoir une claire vision
de son futur et je vois que le speaker
l'ont expliqué au président a parlé du
président barack obama
pour moi c'est quelqu'un de wau je
dirais par ce pilier parti de rien comme
il a si bien dit mais ce sur quoi je
veux maxence tués 7 en relation avec
l'ancien président bill clinton
je sais pas combien de personnes ont une
idée de la relation qu'il avait avec
button pour rappel bill clinton et sa
femme font partie des personnes qui ont
aidé à financer la campagne de barack
obama
ils ont levé plus de 4 milliards de
dollars pour la campagne de barack obama
donc c'est une relation qu'ils ont
tissés qui a permis à barack obama de
pouvoir tirer profit et je lise à un
attique dignement où il était dit que
les zones où barack obama n'était pas en
mesure d'y aller ou d'y accéder à cause
de sa couleur de peau à cause des
préjugés que les uns et les autres
avaient su son profil en tant que
candidat aux élections
bill clinton et sa femme étaient ces
personnes là qui allaient dans cette
zone à
de parler de barrage afin de développer
des idées quant à sa possibilité canton
potentiel qu'il avait de devenir
président des états unis d'amérique
donc sa relation avec bill clinton lui a
donné aujourd'hui en quelque sorte
d'être ce qu'il est devenu
je dirais pas que c'est tout mais ça a
contribué à ce qu'il est devenu tout
mauvais est de me voir jouer
quotidiennement au golf avec bill
clinton dont je vous demande pas de de
jouer pour le temps au golf avec
monsieur koffi par exemple mais je veux
dire qu'il faut il faudrait établi une
relation qui vous donnerait de maximiser
dans le futur au délà d'avoir une claire
vision de son futur établis ou élargit
son réseau dépend également des lieux
que nous fréquentons tu ne peux pas dire
que tu veux être président est à la
limite si vous me le permettez vous vous
retrouvez toujours dans les boîtes de
nuit
la corrélation serait difficile à faire
il ya quelqu'un qui me disait une fois
qu' on ne devient grand qu'en voyant
pour grandes personnes pour devenir
grand il faut dire que tu puisse exposer
à la grandeur donc si tu veux atteindre
un certain niveau dans la vie tu veux
atteindre un bon nombre d'objectifs il
te faut être dans les environnements qui
vont conditionner cela tu ne peux pas
dire je veux être président était
toujours dans les couloirs non il
faudrait que tu es la posture du
candidat qu'il te faut être il faudrait
que tu puisses être dans les lieux où il
peut faut être et donc ici bon vous avez
par exemple certaines conférences de
leadership qui s'est passé à busan
organisé par mtn et le conférencier
s'était d'abord et quoi donald kaberuka
de la bête et pendant cette conférence
j'ai eu l'occasion de me frotter à la
grandeur en quelque sorte de pouvoir
échanger avec ces grands banquiers parce
que pour ma part en tant que banque hier
ce sont les modèles ce sont des gens que
je ne dirais pas un penher surtout les
gens que j'apprécie énormément et de qui
j'aimerais apprendre donc je suis allé
vers eux échanger avec eux et à chaque
fois qu'il ya des conférences de
leadership ya les conférences sur le
développement personnel sur ces choses
là que nous donnerons de faire la
différence
je m'attelle à y être pas parce que j'ai
pas d'autres occupations mais parce que
j'ai un objectif parce que j'ai une
vision claire de mon futur est
que je veux être et en tant que jeu
comme vous en tant qu'étudiant que vous
être il faudrait que vous puissiez
cultiver et développer ce tam ont la
solution développée ce désir là de vous
exposer à la grandeur ok le dernier
point où le troisième élément qui
aiderait quant à maximiser son réseau
quand a élargi et accroître la qualité
de ses connexions
il s'agirait de maintenir et
d'entretenir les connexions acquise je
râle on se dit mais je les ai rencontrés
à cinq ans j'ai plus besoin d'échanger
avec lui mais il est important vous
puissiez maintenir au relationnel
le relationnel comme je le dis est ce
qui vous donnerait de faire la
différence à la sortie de cette
conférence quand tu prendras le numéro
de ton voisin quand tu prendras les
numéros des speakers il faudrait que au
moins une fois par mois
tu puisses leur envoyant un message
takeri de leur état de santé
savoir ce qui les concerne de cette
manière par exemple pour les directeurs
d'entreprises qui sont ici qu'en tire
une opportunité et qu'il est père il est
permanemment en contact avec toi son
premier réflexe est tien et engins avec
qui j'échange souvent qui a tel profil
ça pourrait marcher avec le besoin de
l'entreprise peut que c'est vraiment
vous exhortez contart maintenez votre
connexion quant à entretenir et
développer votre relationnel
pour ma part c'est l'un des éléments
clés qui vous donnerait de faire la
différence dans pourri capitule hâtives
il faudrait vous rappelez de trois
éléments clés le premier élément serait
d'avoir une vision claire de son futur
parce que seule ta vision te donnerai de
développer ton cercle d'amis qu'on n'a
pas de vision claire du machrek tout le
monde et si t'arrives de marché avec les
amis de serge aurier
vous aurez les résultats que ces jours
ya eu par exemple voilà ce qu'il
faudrait que votre vision vous guide
quant à vos connexions au delà de la
vision il faudrait que vous puissiez
être dans les lieux qu'il faut atteindre
les conférences participé à l'élévation
et au delà de ce point
le dernier point je serai de maintenir
les connexions attise je vous remercie
je souhaite bon vent à l'insulté d'être
rapidement